ça j'ouvre maintenant le second débat de
ce sens public vous le savez on fait le
choix éditorial le plus souvent possible
de le décaler volontairement de
l'actualité du jour de prendre du recul
ce soir la réponse de l'Église
catholique après les révélations du
rapport de la commission sauver c'était
le 5 octobre 2021 à l'époque vous en
souvenez sans doute ce chiffre comme un
électrochoc 330 000 personnes victimes
de prêtres ou de laïques liés à l'église
14 mois plus tard - 2 40 ont obtenu
réparation ça s'explique on va
évidemment tenter de comprendre pourquoi
avec mes invités mais d'abord ce
reportage signé Fabien rekker il est
parti à la rencontre de l'une des
victimes en Isère et d'une association à
Paris Bordeaux Rennes ou encore
Strasbourg ces dernières semaines
plusieurs diocèses ont été secouées par
des affaires de pédocriminalité devant
cette église parisienne à la sortie de
la messe les paroissiens sont partagés
entre tristesse et lassitude c'est
abyssal comme comme problème ce qui est
déjà bien c'est que ça soit
pris en compte et que et que voilà les
chrétiens le regardent ce problème et ce
sont un peu démuni devant et bien
évidemment mais c'est une grande
tristesse une grande tristesse une
grande et une lassitude et un risque de
perte de confiance au fur et à mesure
parce que ça fait quand même beaucoup et
on a l'impression que les affaires se
poursuivent et ne se termine jamais il y
a un an pourtant la commission
indépendante sur les abus sexuels dans
l'église la science rendait un rapport
explosif après deux années d'enquête
estimant à plus de 330 000 le nombre de
victimes d'abus dans le cadre religieux
depuis les années 50 des victimes comme
Nanou couturier et sa soeur et nous
avons été abusé toutes les deux par
trois prêtres Maristes qui professaient
dans l'église qui était juste en face de
notre maison et ces trois Maristes
passaient quand ils venaient manger un
coup dans la chambre de masseur un coup
dans la mienne et c'était vraiment des
abus qui étaient fréquents j'ai mis
beaucoup de temps pour réaliser que
j'étais une victime oui parce que j'ai
pas eu 50 ans après l'effet que décrit
Nanou couturier sont aujourd'hui
prescrits pour recueillir la parole de
victimes comme Nanou l'Église a créé
l'an dernier une instance lignée chargée
de verser des compensations financières
quelle a plafonner à 60000 euros pour
Nanou le contenu est pas elle a fondé
une association qui regroupe des
centaines de victimes exigent une
meilleure prise en compte de leur
souffrance quand j'ai des victimes qui
me disent voilà j'ai eu l'ignire enfin
au téléphone je suis le numéro 584 et
j'aurai un rendez-vous avec un référent
fin du deuxième semestre 2023 bah vous
vous dites le 500 ça veut dire que les
500 qui restent derrière c'est dans 2024
2025 et c'est pas possible les instances
sont vraiment aveugles complètement ou
ont décidé d'être aveugle parce qu'elle
travaille pour le bien-être de l'église
et pour protéger ses deniers
reproche surtout alignir un manque
d'indépendance puisque l'instant c'est
financé par la Conférence des évêques de
France du côté de l'unir on mettait en
garde sur le décalage entre les missions
de l'instance et les attentes des
associations de victimes on est dans une
démarche de gré à gré que les évêques
proposent aux personnes aussi mais donc
ce qui est proposé c'est demande une
adhésion des personnes victimes
effectivement on n'est pas dans un
système de droit établi codifié ni dans
une réponse judiciaire donc l'enjeu
n'est pas seulement d'entrée dans une
démarche de d'indemnisation ou de
compensation financière mais bien
d'avoir une réponse globale en vue d'un
mieux-être de la personne qui a subi des
violences sexuelles au cours de sa
minorité à ce jour l'inhir dit avoir
reçu 1102 demandes et accompagné 260
personnes pour accélérer le traitement
des affaires d'agression sexuelles dans
l'église les évêques de France viennent
par ailleurs d'annoncer la création d'un
tribunal pénal canonique
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités dans ce second débat sur
Véronique Margron bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes soeur dominicaine théologienne
présidente de la conférence des
religieuses et religieux de France
Samuel Etienne liévène pardon bonsoir
bienvenue à vous la directeur de la
rédaction des dromadaires le pèlerin
Aymeric de Bézenac bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi collectif des fidèles agir
pour notre église et Guillaume barré
resté à mes côtés éditorialiste
politique je voudrais qu'on démarre on
reviendra sur évidemment
la question de la réparation le temps
pris pourquoi si peu de victimes
aujourd'hui ont touché ont touché cette
réparation mais il y a d'abord quand
même ce
cauchemar ravivait le mois dernier quand
le cardinal Jean-Pierre Ricard a avoué
des faits je le citerai préhensible
commis à 35 ans sur une adolescente âgée
de 14 ans sur Véronique Margron
c'était il y a cinq semaines avec un
tout petit peu de recul comment vous
sentez est-ce que vous dites c'est
décourageant c'est quoi votre état
d'esprit c'est difficile de se dire que
ça n'est pas décourageant bien sûr que
c'est décourageant comment dire autre
chose d'autant plus que quand il s'agit
des vêks d'archevêque ou de cardinaux
c'est toute une sonde des hommes mais
au-delà des hommes c'est toute une
symbolique dans l'Église catholique qui
est atteinte puisque c'est sont ces
hommes qui dirigent les autres qui qui
font en principe ce qu'on appelle la
communion dans l'église de la part d'un
cardinal c'est un électeur du pape donc
évidemment la puissance symbolique est à
la hauteur aussi de la déflagration
provoquée dans dans l'ensemble de du
peuple catholique et y compris moi donc
bien sûr que c'est décourageant après la
question c'est derrière il y a des
victimes un des milliers des milliers
des milliers de victimes et donc pour
ces victimes là il n'est pas possible de
se décourager et un sentiment de
trahison aussi j'ai lu que vous aviez
dit ça dans une bien sûr si vous voulez
parce que c'est de la trahison
profondément humaine comment c'est
possible que quelqu'un qui doit prendre
soin et en particulier soin de de plus
fragile que sont des enfants ou des
adultes qui sont rendus vulnérables tout
simplement parce qu'ils sont dans un
lien de confiance donc comment c'est
possible de les trahir à ce point et
commencer possible de trahir l'Évangile
pour moi qui essaie d'être chrétienne
comment c'est possible de travailler
l'évangile de cette façon pas par la
violence la plus la plus abject
Samuel liévène c'est bon vous l'avez dit
mais il faut rappeler ce que représente
Jean-Pierre Ricard dans le dans
l'épiscopat français et peut-être ce que
vos lecteurs ont dit parce que à chaque
fois le pèlerin c'est un réceptacle
aussi de de l'opinion des des fidèles et
des catholiques c'est vrai que c'est un
hebdomadaire qui accompagne depuis
bientôt 150 ans et qui est un peu le
reflet la caisse de résonance gérer de
ce christianisme populaire à travers
tout le pays donc évidemment depuis
qu'on traite ses affaires ça va faire
une vingtaine d'années
particulièrement 5-7 ans depuis
l'affaire prénat en France on reçoit
beaucoup de courrier évidemment
on pensait être arrivé au maximum lors
du dévoilement du rapport sauvé en
octobre de l'année dernière 2021
grosso modo tout le monde pensait que le
gros de la déflagration était était là
sous nos yeux que maintenant ça touche
carrément des responsables de l'Église
de France vous l'avez dit des évêques
qui sont un petit peu le support des
communautés des gens qui enseignent la
communauté qui disent ce qui est le bien
ce qui est le mal qu'aujourd'hui ce soit
les évêques eux-mêmes qui soient mis en
cause de reprise président de la
Conférence des évêques de France alors
il a été de 2001 à 2007 voilà donc
président de la conférence avec de
France est toujours aujourd'hui jusque à
ce qui jusqu'à ce qu'il soit démis en
fait potentiel électeur du pape cardinal
de moins de 80 ans on touche vraiment là
au sommet au sommet de la hiérarchie
catholique et donc oui on a
effectivement atteint là dans le je
dirais dans le la déstabilisation voir
le dégoût le mot revient souvent dans
les quelque chose voilà c'est que c'est
évidemment très violent
on se demande encore une fois si le fond
est touché ou sur encore pire mais c'est
vrai qu'on reçoit énormément de courrier
du courrier qui était aussi parfois même
carrément un passage aux aveux parce que
des gens qui se trouvent démunis et qui
ont depuis 50 ans on l'a vu dans votre
reportage pas osé prendre la parole le
fond dans un tire-lieu un journal au
fond qui vous accompagne devient ce
tire-le se tire-lieu pardon où vous
pouvez prendre la parole et aujourd'hui
on a vraiment à faire à finalement des
gens des chrétiens de bonne volonté qui
se sont engagés toute leur vie même
s'ils ne perdent pas la foi en tout cas
ils sont bien décidés à poursuivre
quelque part sans l'institution c'est
pas des contours très nettes dans leur
esprit mais c'est quand même ce qui ce
qui domine dans les dans les témoignages
c'est à dire voilà maintenant il va
falloir poursuivre seul en fait ce sont
beaucoup de gens qui se retrouvent en
réalité seul démunis alors Aymeric de
bezenac c'est pas le choix que un effet
puisque vous êtes mobilisé avec ce
collectif de fidèles pour faire de
l'église je vous cite une maison sûre et
vous participez à un certain nombre
d'instances qui ont été créés à la suite
de la de la commission sauvée la maison
sur le maître mot c'est le mot confiance
comment faire confiance quand de tels
actes voilà atteignent les ce qu'on
disait les plus hauts dignitaires de
l'Église il est clair que la confiance
elle est elle est fortement endommagée
sinon rompu c'est évident
depuis un an qu'agir pour notre église
existe on est sur une ligne de crête
dans le sens où à la fois on accompagne
les diocèses dans la réception du
rapport de la science et les fidèles
dans la réception de ce même rapport
donc ça signifie que en interne
notamment avec la Conférence des évêques
de France on va travailler avec les
élèves pour les aider à prendre la
pleine mesure de ce phénomène systémique
et en externe on est là aussi pour dire
aux évêques ben là vous faites n'importe
quoi il y a un moment il faut arrêter de
il faut excusez-moi il c'est des
conneries qu'il y a une prise de
conscience qui est pas généralisée c'est
en fait c'est un peu ça si je devais
décrire le phénomène systémique c'est
une pieuvre aujourd'hui à mon sens
l'Église catholique et les élèves de
France savent qu'il y a une pieuvre qui
existe et cette pieuvre c'est le
phénomène des abus sexuels mais cette
pieuvre elle a plusieurs tentacules ils
ont pas encore vu où est-ce qu'elle se
niche s'est tentacules l'année dernière
c'était les abus sexuels sur mineurs les
agressions par les agressions sexuelles
sur mineur cette année avec notamment
l'affaire Ricard mais surtout la faire
sentier qui était avant dont on a moins
entendu parler dans la presse nationale
on parle
d'atteindre sexuelle ou d'arrêt relation
sexuelle sur majeur avec des phonèmes et
des phénomènes d'emprise donc oui la
confiance elle est fortement entachée
mais dans le même temps on comprend que
il y a une un début de prise de
conscience mais que cette prise de
conscience est très progressive et qu'il
faut l'accompagner pour qu'au fur et à
mesure on déterre toutes les on sort
toutes les poubelles comme on l'a dit
dans le cadre de notre mort alors je
vous propose d'entendre tout de suite
l'actuel président de la Conférence des
Évêques de France Monseigneur Éric de
Moulins Beaufort c'est lui qui avait lu
vous en souvenez peut-être la lettre
d'aveux de Jean-Pierre Ricard et voici
ce qu'il déclarait juste après lors de
la même conférence de presse
vous pouvez vous représenter l'estime
dans laquelle il est tenu par nous qu'il
avait élu deux fois comme notre
président
et qui avons été les témoins de ton
épiscopat à Grenoble à Montpellier et à
Bordeaux
sur Margron un cardinal qui se dénonce
cette à ma connaissance une démarche
inédite il y a eu une enquête
préliminaire du Vatican il y a une
enquête préliminaire du parquet de
Marseille
on peut imaginer que les faits sont
prescrits donc il y a aussi cette
dimension là qui est toujours très très
difficile à accepter et à analyser je
pense d'autant plus de la part des
victimes c'est à dire que très bien il y
a une dénonciation mais tellement
tardive tellement bien sûr il y a une
dénonciation extrêmement tardive et que
comme vous le disiez
de toute façon comme un signalement
avait été fait une enquête préliminaire
allait s'ouvrir de la part de la justice
de notre pays et par ailleurs la justice
canonique donc était élastique était
elle même saisie donc tant mieux qu'il
ait lui-même parlé
maintenant vous nous dites il a parlé
sous pression judiciaire
ou j'espère que non mais en tout cas la
pression elle est là on peut pas dire le
contraire et puis nous nous enfin quand
même tout ce qu'on évoquait à l'instant
de ces crimes systémiques tout ce que
nous connaissons quand même de ce que
c'est que la pédocriminalité font que
il se dénonce mais qui peut dire
aujourd'hui quelle est la réalité des
faits en tout cas ce que nous entendons
c'est la version de Jean-Pierre Ricard
il nous faut attendre l'enquête ou pour
savoir quelle est la version judiciaire
ou la réalité au comportement
répréhensible pour l'instant sont des
termes qui n'existent pas vraiment
dans notre droit pénal donc voilà il
faut que l'enquête soit là et il y a son
terme pour nous sachions exactement mais
en tout cas voilà on peut de fait de se
représenter comme le disait Eric de mon
imbofort la puissance de la déflagration
d'abord moi j'ai pensé avant tout la
déflagration pour la personne victime
en tout cas celle-ci c'est pas si
j'espère qu'il n'y en a pas d'autres
mais nous n'en savons rien aujourd'hui
de Jean-Pierre Ricard d'abord pour elle
qui de fait voilà pour des tas de
raisons dont le silence dans l'église
parce que c'est aussi simple facile si
les personnes ne peuvent pas apporter
pleinte auprès de la justice de notre
pays c'est sans doute de par tout ce
qu'on y sont tout ce que nous
connaissons sur la mémoire dissociatif
qui fait que c'est très très compliqué
parce que fin de compte le cheminement
intérieur intime psychique est très long
mais c'est aussi parce que l'Église a
tellement caché les faits que les deux
les deux phénomènes se conjuguent et que
quand la personne le souhaite et bien il
est trop tard oui il y a beaucoup de
victimes qui qui ont été recensés par la
commission sauvée par la science qui
avait tenté de de dénoncer l'effet près
de la moitié je dis ça de mémoire
semelle liévène
le pèlerin a commencé vous nous l'avez
dit ça fait quoi une petite dizaine
d'années peut-être à à dénoncer a été
fait à essayer d'alerter sur ces faits
comment la Conférence des évêques donc
comment le la hiérarchie de l'église
française a-t-elle réagi est-ce que
c'est un déni est-ce que vous employez
le terme d'omerta j'entends le mot très
fort de pieuvre un pieuvre moi ça me
fait penser à la mafia donc quand vous
employez ce mot-là quel mot vous
employez vous je pense d'ailleurs qu'il
y a une première période qui est
intéressante que j'ai que moi-même
connue comme journaliste qui est la
période 2000-2010 ou en gros la
communication de l'Église de France
tournée autour de on a eu l'affaire
piquant piquant cet évêque en Normandie
qui voilà avait déjà été jugé et
condamné pour non dénonciation d'actes
pédophiles dans son dans son diocèse par
un prêtre et donc
l'expiscopat français était réputé en
fait avoir mis à jour toutes ces
procédures il y avait une petite
plaquette qui était parfois mise à jour
et puis à grand renfort de communication
pour dire voilà tous les problèmes
systémiques qui existent ailleurs en
Allemagne en Irlande aux États-Unis il y
aura jamais chez nous on n'a pas les
structures qui peuvent en même temps
expliquer
l'importance du nombre dans ces pays-là
c'est pas le même pays c'est pas les
mêmes structures circuler il y a rien à
voir en gros et à ce moment-là on avait
déjà c'était 2012 fait une enquête au
moment où Benoît XVI essayait de
nettoyer les écuries d'ogias par le haut
c'est à dire qu'il était conscient qu'il
y avait un gros problème il savait pas
trop comment le prendre il avait
commencé à mettre en place des
structures pour inciter les épices
coppas à agir mais en France on sentait
bien que s'intéresser à la question
surtout en plus pour un hebdomadaire
catholique c'était particulièrement mal
pris la reproche est très clair ça a été
oui c'était clairement reproché à ce
moment-là de mais enfin comment vous
pouvez
sous-entendre qu'il y aurait des
problèmes alors qu'il y en a pas tant
que ça il y a quelques cas isolés
c'était un petit peu ça et je me
souviens qu'on avait des une discussion
à ce moment-là et donc par la suite il y
a eu tout un mouvement de voilà de
révélation à l'international et puis la
faire prénat en 2015 en France le
diocèse de Lyon puis ensuite le le film
Dieu
grâce à Dieu et le documentaire sur Arte
en 2019 sur sur les religieuses abusées
là ça a vraiment été le mouvement je
dirais qui fait que tout tous ces
retourné et la presse dans son ensemble
et la presse catholique en particulier
on enquêté alors chez nos lecteurs c'est
intéressant parce que là on est dans les
années 2010 au début c'est quand même
quand même vous exagérez vous vous avez
quand même tendance à tirer sur
l'ambulance l'église des l'église est
déjà si fragile ne nous accablez pas
avec ses affaires là et peu à peu on est
allé vers un retournement et le gérer le
le rapport sauvé était le coup de grâce
aujourd'hui on a plus du tout de
courrier ou de mails ou de nous disons
nous reprochons de de reporter ses
affaires bien au contraire aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt qu'est-ce qu'on fait
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
cette institution qui est par terre qui
est discrédité ça va faire partie de
notre débats
qu'est-ce que vous faites quand vous
avez des fidèles vous dites qui vous
envoie des lettres et qui confessent
avoir été abusé qu'est-ce que vous en
faites après ah ben justement on
s'appuie sur ce qui existe aujourd'hui
il y a quand même eu un travail qui a
été fait depuis la commission sauvée
pour leur dire à qui ils peuvent
désormais s'adresser et pendant
longtemps ça a été d'ailleurs la demande
c'est concrètement qu'est-ce que
l'information tout à fait vous faites
une conférence sur la question des abus
sexuels tout simplement dans une salle
voilà où on vous accueille en région et
à la fin de la soirée il y a toujours
les gens qui viennent nous poser des
questions mais il y a ceux qui viennent
carrément vous confier ce qu'ils n'ont
jamais confié à personne et ils vous
voient comme un journaliste certes mais
un petit peu comme quelqu'un comme un
référent comme un tiers qui va pouvoir
leur dire ce qu'il doit faire c'est
particulièrement au départ des
stabilisants on va on va rappeler avec
Steve Jourdain dans une minute vraiment
le contenu de de ce rapport de la
commission sauvé mais sur cette question
de l'accueil de la parole de victime ça
fait partie du du travail que vous
essayez de faire avec avec votre
collectif agir pour notre église il faut
aussi former les fidèles d'une certaine
façon à recueillir la parole parce que
ça ça arrive alors
agir pour notre église n'est pas une
association de victimes on est une
fidèle donc
comment dire on peut on peut former
effectivement des fidèles à recevoir la
parole de victime mais on va pas se
substituer à une association de victimes
bien sûr et former des fidèles à
recevoir un témoignage de victimes c'est
à la fois lui donner les clés pour
écouter et recevoir
la parole de la victime et c'est aussi
lui donner des clés pour orienter la
victime que ce soit vers le parquet que
ce soit vers France victime
ou en troisième lieu et je mets la
priorité en de manière très claire vers
la cellule d'écoute du diocèse
donc on fait pas de on va pas faire de
dire donc vous dites aller vers la
justice des hommes oui prioritairement
sans hésiter c'est prioritaire la
compétence c'est du côté de France
victime ensuite les cellules d'écoute
dédiocèses c'est la qualité est variable
alors on va donc revenir sur ce ce
rapport de la commission alors je vais
rappeler hein c'est la commission
indépendante sur les abus sexuels dans
l'église la science la présidé par le
magistrat Jean-Marc Sauvé elle
déclenchait donc il y a 14 mois
maintenant une attente immense reconnue
d'ailleurs par Monseigneur Luc Crepy qui
est le président de la cellule
permanente de prévention et lutte contre
la pédophilie
il y a une immense attente attente de la
part des personnes victimes d'abord
attente de beaucoup de fidèles et même
je dirais de une grande majorité ou de
l'ensemble des fidèles alors voilà pour
cette attente exprimée quelques semaines
après le la remise du rapport de la
commission sauvée Steve Jourdain vous
pouvez nous rejoindre sur sur ce plateau
rebonsoir Steve donc pour vraiment être
didactique nous rappeler les grandes
lignes de ce travail un chiffre choc
Thomas pour commencer 216 216000 comme
le nombre de personnes aujourd'hui
majeures qui auraient été agressé par un
prêtre ou un religieux alors qu'elles
étaient mineurs le chiffre monte même
jusqu'à 330 000 si l'on compte les
victimes de laïque liées à l'église il
s'agit par exemple des encadrants dans
les mouvements de jeunesse l'ensemble de
ces violences sexuelles aurait été
commises entre 1950 et 2020 quelques
semaines après la publication du rapport
le président de la commission était
auditionné au Sénat il dénonçait une
défaillance généralisée écoutez-le
il y a
une défaillance que nous qualifions de
systémique une défaillance
institutionnelle c'est à dire que la
Commission pense que l'Église catholique
à la fois n'a pas su
entendre n'a pas su voir dans certains
cas de manière certaine n'a pas voulu
voir
n'a pas su capter des signaux faibles
donc 14 mois après les révélations de la
commission sauvée les recommandations
qui avaient été faites on en est où
alors la commission sauvée avait fait 45
recommandations parmi elles la
reconnaissance de la responsabilité de
l'Église dans ces violences et sur ce
point elle avait été entendue puisque
l’instance de réparation a été créée
avec pour objectif d'indemniser
notamment les victimes un an après on va
voir les chiffres
1550 victimes de violences sont
adressées aux deux commissions de
réparation mise en place 450 victimes
ont effectivement été reconnues 3 ont
obtenu une réparation financière c'est
beaucoup trop peu pour les associations
qui déplorent un dispositif
sous-dimensionné demain et puis alors il
y a la dimension évidemment du Vatican
au Vatican est-ce que les choses ont
bougé depuis 14 mois alors au départ on
a eu l'impression que le pape prenait la
chose très à coeur écouter ce qu'il
déclarait quelques semaines après la
publication du rapport
décidément
je désire exprimer aux victimes ma
tristesse ma douleur pour les
traumatismes subis et aussi ma honte
notre honte ma honte pour une trop
longue incapacité de l'église à les
mettre au centre de ses préoccupations
sauvée soient reçus au Vatican mais
officiellement raison de problèmes
d'agenda du Pape le rendez-vous avait
été ajourné et n'a jamais été
reprogrammée est-ce du au fait que
certains au sein du monde catholique
contestent les conclusions les chiffres
et la méthode mise en place pour ce
rapport en tout cas à l'heure où l'on
parle aucune nouvelle invitation pour la
Commission n'a été envoyé de merci Steve
Jourdain sommelierven pourquoi le pape
n'a-t-il toujours pas reçu la commission
sauvée il y a un mot qui passe pas
auprès du pape c'est le mot systémique
alors Jean-Marc Sauvé en donne lui-même
une définition dans les nombreuses
interviews qu'il a qu'il a accordé
alors je pars un peu sous le contrôle de
sur Macron mais ce qu'il a bien voulu
dire tout à l'heure sérieux on a parlé
de de d'omerta on a parlé de pieuvre on
a parlé de mafia il veut dire par là que
systémique c'est pas que il y a eu en
gros un plan diabolique des évêques pour
que ce pour que tous ces toutes ces tous
ces crimeux en revanche non c'est que
les évêques pour que la parole ne se
libère pas vraiment les évêques ayant
qui viennent témoigner ne soit pas
vraiment entendu voilà c'est que les
évêques en revanche ayant eu
connaissance de ces de ces crimes n'ont
pas fait ce qu'il fallait pour les
empêcher à l'avenir et c'est en ce sens
est-ce qu'il faut apporter une précision
supplémentaire que le mot systémique a
été employé et à Rome ça ne passe pas
d'ailleurs récemment les piscopa
Italiens en corps pris position pour
exprimer son désaccord à l'égard de la
démarche française et en Italie
d'ailleurs eu égard à la taille de
l'église et est-ce qu'elle représente il
y a pas encore eu véritablement de de
tsunami et euh a priori vu ce qui s'est
passé en France c'est ce qu'on nous
racontait il y a une quinzaine d'années
il y aurait de quoi s'attendre au pire
donc euh pour le moment en tout cas le
mot systémique ne passe pas et la et la
démarche de la Commission ne semble pas
être en odeur de de santé au Vatican
mais il y a au sein de l'Église
catholique en France vous en faites
partie évidemment mais j'imagine aussi
au Vatican
beaucoup de de croyants et de religieux
qui qui poussent pour que la parole se
libère et pour que pour que enfin le
ménage soit fait donc c'est quoi ces
deux courants qui s'opposent est-ce
qu'on peut c'est de la politique aussi
de Vatican jour on n'est pas on n'est
pas naïf ici donc c'est possible que ce
soit des courants qui s'opposent je
pense surtout que c'est des prises de
conscience qui sont pas au même niveau
autrement dit tant que il y a une sorte
de grande injustice qui est que tant que
vous n'avez pas été percuté dans votre
propre cher par le récit des victimes
vous croyez que tout ça c'est une sorte
de problème plus pseudo intellectuel et
que en prenant des mesures un peu à la
marge de toute chose qu'il faut faire ça
va aller alors que non ça va pas aller
du tout c'est à dire que tant qu'il n'y
a pas une indignation
au coeur même de l'ensemble de l'Église
catholique et de de
du peuple des fidèles comme de la
hiérarchie comme de l'ensemble des
supérieurs religieux pour parler de ma
propre boutique on ne prendra pas les
décisions qui s'imposent c'est ça la
question c'est que il faut une
indication suffisante pour qu'on se dise
non il y a des choses qui doivent
absolument être réformés le rapport au
secret aussi Lens à la clarté envers le
peuple de Dieu qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas un enfant tout de même enfin voilà
c'est tous ces éléments là et et cela ça
ne se fait que que parce que vous avez
été profondément indignés et scandalisé
de ce que vous avez entendu du
témoignage effectif alors on est en
duplex en visioconférence avec Nanou
couturier on vous a entendu dans le
reportage de Fabien ricquer longuement
je rappelle que vous êtes présidente de
l'Association des abusés sexuels de vous
avez vous-même on l'a dit dans le
reportage avec votre sœur était victime
il y a ce chiffre moi qui m'a frappé on
est en dessous des 40 personnes
indemnisées comment vous l'expliquez ce
chiffre
c'est vrai que surtout sur 14 mois
moi avec du recul aujourd'hui je dis que
l'Église je vais parler avec mes mots
j'ai débarrassé du bébé sur le plan
indemnisation en moment deux instances
ces deux instances je suis persuadée ne
s'attendait pas du tout à avoir une
telle tâche ce qui résume à qu'il y a
tellement de victimes du côté de
Lignières qui sont de plus de 1000 du
côté de la CRR qui sont un peu plus de
500 et là comment peuvent-elles
s'organiser effectivement pour que ça
aille plus vite puisque c'est ce qu'on
lui reproche le plus cette lenteur et on
lui reproche comme je dis on a deux deux
reproches à faire si la lenteur et le
montant la lenteur pour y remédier
qu'est-ce qu'elle pourrait faire pour
l'instant il n'y a que des bénévoles ce
qui veut dire que ces bénévoles
travaillent la journée il y a 6 heures
de téléphonie disponible par semaine et
pour recevoir pour les référents
reçoivent les victimes
il doit pas y avoir beaucoup de temps
non plus dans l'idéal moi ce que je
pensais c'était de mettre alors pas des
temps plein puisque
Marie des reins me l'a expliqué des
temps plein pour écouter des victimes
toute la journée c'est pas possible ça
démolit mais elle va être peut-être des
mi-temps supplémentaires vous nous dites
il y a pas assez de moyens et pas assez
de professionnels alors il y a deux
instances de réparation sur ma grande il
y a des il y a des professionnels entre
guillemets dans dans l'une des deux
c'est ça
dans celles présidé par Antoine Garapon
donc du côté des personnes qui ont été
victimes de religieux de religieuses
il y a aujourd'hui beaucoup de
professionnels alors comme le disait
madame qui ne sont pas à temps plein
quoique certains sont quasi à temps
plein donc on a les deux situations
c'est à dire on a des bénévoles qui sont
à temps plein en fin de compte
aujourd'hui on a des professionnels
bénévoles qui sont à ce qu'ils peuvent
et puis on a des professionnels
rémunérées indemniser qui sont à quasi
temps plein ou à des gros à des gros
mi-temps parce que de fait tout le souci
est de monter en charge par rapport au
nombre de personnes même s'il y a des
professionnels leurs moyens sont trop
faits par rapport à l'ampleur des des
personnes entrantes
je suis vraiment désolé mais je voudrais
pas qu'il confusion on parle et on l'a
dit avec Steve Jourdain il y A 330 000
personnes c'est le ça a été le chiffre
quand on dit prêtre et laïque dans
l'environnement de l'église sur ces 330
000 si je ne me trompe pas il y en a un
peu plus de 1500 1550 qui sont
considérés comme pouvait être indemnisés
on est à autour de 40 qui l'ont dans une
en tout cas en dessous d'ores et déjà
été indemnisés donc voilà pour pour
l'ordre de grandeur mais on est d'accord
que les moyens sont pas suffisants
aujourd'hui je parle des moyens humains
oui dans les moyens humains sont
peut-être pas encore suffisants la
commission Garapon elle est passée du 10
à 25 personnes aujourd'hui qui écoutent
qui accompagne mais il faut voir aussi
que le processus il est nécessairement
long il est très coûteux humainement le
processus Pau y compris et avant tout
pour les personnes victimes puisqu'il
consiste d'abord à pouvoir reconnaître
la gravité de ce qu'elles ont subi et
des traumas qui sont non suivis souvent
toute leur vie et donc ça ça se fait pas
en deux heures d'attente d'entretien
mais en plusieurs entretiens et d'aller
jusqu'à la réparation des réparations
morales et des réparations financières
donc on est aussi sur un processus qui
est long vous pouvez pas dire en trois
séances ça va être réglé donc ça aussi
ça joue enfin la justice restauratrice à
partir du moment où elle met la victime
au centre du processus et bien faut
aussi prendre le pas de la victime enfin
vous pouvez pas interroger discuter avec
les gens enfin être dans une
conversation aussi difficile aussi
intime aussi douloureuse je sais pas moi
trois jours de suite c'est pas possible
donc il y a aussi cette question là en
rajoutant en plus que ces deux
commissions ont dû inventer une
méthodologie puisqu'en France rien de
tout cela n'existait pour aucun milieu
est-ce qu'on a des exemples justement à
l'étranger ou un rapport sur les abus
sexuels dans l'église a été fait et où
une procédure d'indemnisation aurait été
mise en place et où ça aurait fonctionné
alors oui on a des exemples par exemple
en Belgique en Hollande on a des
exemples y compris donc en Europe aux
États-Unis bien marché
sur le temps long quand même là aussi
c'est à dire sur plusieurs années aucune
de ces commissions m'est arrivé à
fonctionner correctement en un an ça
c'est pas vrai parce qu'il faut aussi de
fait inventer une façon de faire qui
soit respectueuse des personnes victimes
qui qui aillent au bout du processus
pour nous qui prennent en compte les
instituts religieux dont son membre ou
dont était membre des agresseurs parce
que c'est ce sont ces instituts
religieux qui payent donc il faut aussi
qu'il soit à un moment donné évidemment
non seulement consulter mais que la
confiance se fasse pour parce que c'est
lui qui vont devoir
observer les recommandations posées par
la commission Garapon donc si vous
voulez c'est enfin il y a quelque chose
qui est forcément lent donc maintenant
la question c'est que maintenant qu'il y
a un tout petit peu de recul c'est la
nécessaire monter en charge des deux
commissions maintenant qu'elles ont
acquis un peu de méthodologie enfin plus
de méthodologie voilà et qu'elles ont de
l'expérience après il y a un autre
problème et et grâce à vous j'espère
qu'on va en sortir un peu qui est de
toute façon les deux commissions ne sont
pas assez connues donc il n'y a pas
assez de victimes qui contactent ces
commissions qu'il y a plus de victimes
que les 330 000 mais ah non mais si vous
voulez pour le moment les deux enfin non
c'est rien d'ailleurs peut-être que oui
mais pour le moment grosso modo 1500
1600 personnes ont contacté ces deux
commissions vous voyez si on compte
dire 200000 même si quand on s'en 000
vous voyez bien qu'on le gap est immense
alors vous vous parlez vous citer
effectivement Antoine Garapon qui est ce
magistrat président de la Commission de
de réparation je vous propose d'entendre
une une des réactions alors c'était en
novembre 2021 il vient d'être nommé
voilà comment il imagine son rôle en
fait une victime très souvent elles sont
un petit peu prisonnées pourvu qu'on
leur demande qu'est-ce que vous demandez
et disent qu'est-ce que je vais demander
j'ai passé j'ai fait trois thérapies une
psychanalyse j'ai divorcé tout ça moi je
la butte à cet abus donc la difficulté
sera de trouver une de trouver une juste
réparation et d'élaborer en relation
avec l'Institut cette réparation
beaucoup de victimes sont découragé de
se trouver face à une institution comme
l'institution religieuse ou comme une
congrégation donc on aura une fonction
d'abord d'accueil d'écoute
d'accompagnement de garantie et si c'est
s'il y a besoin de se substituer pour
pour faire une médiation nous-même
Aymeric de Bézenac il y a cette
dimension moi que je trouve très
importante c'est on l'a un peu évoqué
rapidement tout à l'heure c'est des
victimes qui avaient trouvé
éventuellement le courage de parler il y
a
une deux ou trois décennies et qui ont
donc perdu ce lien de confiance avec
l'Église là se retrouve face à une
institution qui est quand même une
institution liée à l'église vous voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est est-ce que
c'est pas une difficulté intrinsèque de
se processus de de réparation alors oui
paradoxal enfin pas paradoxalement oui
c'est compliqué à mon avis pour une
victime de s'adresser à une instance
issue de l'église
la difficulté qui se devant laquelle on
se trouve c'est que ces instances
elle réparent
donc c'est la justice restaurative
restauratrice pardon
ces instants ça n'existe pas au niveau
étatique il y a rien aujourd'hui en
France qui permet d'indemniser ce que
certains ce que des juristes
s'appelleraient des préjudices prescrits
on a l'ONIAM qui répare les accidents
médicaux on a le FIVA pour les victimes
de l'amiante mais ce sont des des
offices étatique qui vont réparer des
préjudices non encore prescrit
donc aujourd'hui oui oui c'est dur pour
une victime d'aller voir les NIR ou la
CR et je le comprends tout à fait mais
malheureusement je vois pas d'autres
solutions que d'aller voir alors elles
peuvent aller voir effectivement ces
instances mais elles ont aussi le choix
de continuer le combat devant les
juridictions civiles si elle le souhaite
dans la mesure où aujourd'hui
les délais de prescription sont aménagés
par la Cour de cassation je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails très techniques
mais permettent à une victime si elle
veut continuer son combat d'aller devant
le tribunal judiciaire s’amélie Vienne
effectivement sur la question de de ce
chiffre donc on rappelle 216000 ce sont
des victimes directes de prêtres pris si
on élargie au laïque dans dans
l'environnement de l'église on arrive à
330 000 ce sont les chiffres de la
Commission de la science de la
commission sauvée
mais dans la foulée de la remise de ce
rapport au pèlerin vous recevez des
témoignages il y a des gens qui sont
peut-être pas forcément qui ne
recenser là et qui et qui viennent vous
dire moi aussi est-ce que est-ce qu'il y
a eu ce phénomène alors déjà il faut
savoir que les 216 et 330 000 sont des
projections et c'est pas le nombre de
établi on n'a pas les noms des il faut
établir une différence entre le nombre
de personnes réellement additionnées qui
sont réellement manifestées et la
projection c'est très important et au
grosso modo si on considère que sur
environ une population environ 100 000
personnes concernées voilà de se dire
clergé religieux vous en prenez 3% qui
sont des agresseurs et que parmi ces 3%
les modèles et les enfin les
spécialistes de la question estiment que
grosso modo sur une une un demi-siècle
on peut voilà sévir ou agresser 70 à 80
personnes vous faites le compte et vous
y êtes grosso modo à 300000 donc c'est à
la fois un chiffre et en même temps si
vous faites tourner ce compteur
finalement on y arrive de manière assez
enfin on y arrive malheureusement
facilement donc voilà c'est une
projection ce que nous on a constaté ça
c'est intéressant c'est que il y a eu
des témoignages à nouveau personnels qui
sont remontés après le rapport de la
science et
les commissions d'écoute de diocèse ou
France victime ont aussi continué à
recevoir des appels de gens qui aient la
science la sieste mais alors c'est quoi
le numéro la SIA c'était fini et je
crois qu'il faut vraiment se rendre
compte que quand on appartient au petit
milieu un peu informé on manie c'est
c'est acronymes comme si c'était une
évidence beaucoup de gens en fait ont
découvert l'existence de la sieste
et aujourd'hui encore beaucoup de gens
découvrent avec cette émission
l'existence de ces deux commissions
c'est extrêmement compliqué donc il y a
déjà surmonté ce qu'on sait de
difficultés personnelles à prendre la
parole il faut surmonter cette cette
habitude prise d'une église qui
justement ne fonctionne pas sur le mode
de l'écoute de la place faite aux
victimes et en plus de ça il faut
affronter une sorte de voilà de jungle
administrative à laquelle on ne comprend
pas grand chose ça n'arrive pas si
souvent les émissions on en parle en
détail comment on le fait maintenant
nous couturiez je reviens vers vers vous
pardon de ne pas vous donner la parole
un peu plus souvent mais peut-être pour
justement comprendre vous votre retour
d'expérience puisque vous votre
association représente je crois une
vingtaine de victimes c'est ça je dis ça
de mémoire vous allez peut-être être
beaucoup plus précise que moi mais
est-ce que effectivement il y avait une
méconnaissance des instances existantes
des des leviers activés pour pouvoir
être entendu puis éventuellement
indemniser
alors pour avoir régulièrement sur un
groupe de parole un peu plus de 40
victimes oui il en ressort effectivement
des victimes qui qui crient au secours à
qui je dois m'adresser parce que j'en ai
jamais parlé donc ça il y a une réponse
qui est compliquée puisque la science
c'est fini donc moi dans l'idéal je
leur dis qu'il y a unir qui existe la
CRR qui existe aussi avec un numéro de
téléphone et que si vraiment leur
problématique est plus compliqué
elle peut rentrer en contact de de notre
avocats qui est membre d'honneur
justement de notre association maître
Sagnier qui lui va prendre en charge
pour des adultes ou de la non
prescription
alors là oui il y a ça après côté unir
c'est alors la CRM on n'entend pas
beaucoup parler parce que je pense
qu'elle est mieux armée de son côté ça
fait moins de vagues mais c'est
certainement parce qu'elle a moins de
victimes
concernant les livres le désarroi la
colère et c'est terrible parce que les
victimes subissent actuellement
c'est cette lenteur et et là dessus je
reviens sur ce sujet
quand on sort un grand dit que il y a
des gens qui sont il y a 25 personnes
pour pour mettons la CRR les murs n'est
pas dans son quota encore il lui en
manque on a eu un contact téléphonique
où j'ai pu discuter avec Marie Guérin et
il leur manque encore des gens comment
aujourd'hui on peut faire entendre aux
victimes
40 dossiers bouclés en un an oui elles
ont pris de la bouteille si on peut dire
elles ont appris ces instances elles ont
appris à fonctionner et comment le faire
correctement mais je peux pas
comprendre ni pour moi ni pour toutes
ces victimes que 40 victimes en un an
j'ai deux victimes une qui a un numéro
507 et un autre 594 et on lui dit vous
serez contacté par un référent fin du
deuxième semestre 2023 mais c'est
terrible de s'entendre parce que on veut
bien dire oui mais ça peut pas se régler
en un an ça c'est clair mais de nous
dire qu'il faudra attendre des années il
ne faut pas perdre de vue que toutes les
victimes dans l'ensemble sont des années
50 à 70 80 ce sont toutes des personnes
qui ont 70 ans ou plus on va leur
demander d'attendre encore combien de 5
ans 6 ans 8 ans mais elles sont décédées
elles sont mortes et là l'église quelque
part se frottera les mains de toute
façon parce que tu diras bon ben
effectivement ben on a on a épuré le
nombre de
merci beaucoup pour pour ce témoignage à
nous couturier je rappelle Ignir CRR
sont les deux commissions de réparation
voilà si vous nous rejoignez à ce moment
dans le débat et que vous n'avez pas
suivi nos interventions précédentes
peut-être un mot de conclusion
sur Margon sur
les recommandations qui avaient été
faites par la commission sauvée est-ce
qu'il y a des leçons alors je vais
reprendre le terme systémique
c'est-à-dire que peut-être dans le suivi
des prêtres dans le fait que un prêtre
qui a été mis en cause a peut-être pas
pouvoir de nouveau être en contact avec
les fidèles enfin je vous vois lever les
yeux au ciel mais oui mais c'est fait
alors c'est nettement plus fait qu'avant
ça c'est sûr jusqu'à la question est-ce
qu'il ne faut pas dans beaucoup de cas
pouvoir les renvoyer de l'état clérical
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne puissent plus
être prêtre parce que si vous êtes prêt
à être mais que vous pouvez plus rien
faire quel sens ça encore d'être prêtre
donc ce sont des questions qui ne se
posaient quasiment jamais qui
aujourd'hui se pose de façon beaucoup
plus clair ce qu'on
[Musique]
reçoit l'ancien Premier ministre
Jean-Pierre Raffarin ce sera à 8h du
matin sur Public Sénat bonne soirée à
toutes et à tous